[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أعز نهر لي لقد
ولدت في منارة ولدت في جائحة
وستتذوق ما يكفي من الحياة كما
نعرفها لتستاء منا عندما تختفي ،
أنا آسف لأننا كسرنا  بحرك
وسماؤك وأن والدتك اضطرت
إلى منحك قبلة أولى لك من خلال
قناع p100 تفوح منه رائحة الدخان ولكن ابني
تم تحذيرنا من العلماء أخبرنا إذا
لم نتوخى الحذر فلن نطلق العنان
لعدو غير مرئي من  الأدغال
وفي رئتينا ، لكننا ظللنا
نقطع الأدغال لنلتهم كل شيء
بداخلها وعندما أدركنا أن هؤلاء
العلماء كانوا خائفين على حق ،
أفرغ الناس أرفف المتاجر بشكل أسرع
من الأدغال وأن جميع أقنعة العدو غير المرئية
اختفت في الوقت المناسب تمامًا
لميلادك.  ما كنت على وشك أن
يدفعه غولبين لمربح بلا روح ستمائة دولار
مقابل قناع 50 سنتًا عندما تذكرت القناع الذي
استخدمته لحماية
رئتي من مكان حريق يسمى
كاليفورنيا ، احتفظ به بجوار
نوادي الإعصار و bulletpro  من
السترات المزودة بالرقعة التي تقول اضغط ،
وإذا اضطررت إلى حزمها
وتقبيل الوداع أكثر مما تريد ، فأنا
آسف ولكن تم تحذيرنا من العلماء
أخبرنا إذا لم نتوخى الحذر ،
فسنطلق العنان لنوع مختلف  نوع من العدو غير المرئي
يخرج من مصانعنا ومزارعنا
ومنازلنا وسياراتنا وسوف يدخل
البحر في السماء ويغير الحياة كما
نعلم أنها كانت قصة قليلة جدًا لم يرغبوا
في تصديقها حتى الآن ، لذا
سيكون درسك الأول أننا
تتكون القصص من الإنسان والبشر ، والشيء الرائع في
القصص هو أنها
تخضع دائمًا للمراجعة ،
فقد تم تخيلك في منارة ، لذلك سنربيك
بروح حارس المنارة اليقظ الذي يمكن الاعتماد عليه
مع تقديس قوة الطبيعة
و  التزامًا بإنقاذ أكبر قدر
ممكن من الحياة وسأحاول تعليمك
كيفية كتابة قصة أفضل تذكر
الجميع بأن كل يوم هو يوم الأرض ،
لا توصي الأكاديمية الأمريكية لطب الأطفال عادة بالولادات المنزلية
بسبب زيادة المخاطر
لمضاعفات وفيات الرضع ، ولكن في
ضوء هذا الوباء ،
قد تزن النساء الحوامل أكثر من AAP
وتقول إن النساء اللائي يفكرن في الولادة في المنزل
لا ينبغي أن يعانين من أمراض الأم الموجودة مسبقًا أو مرض الأم ،
بما في ذلك مرض السكري أو
تسمم الحمل ، يجب أن
يخططن لتزويد مقدمي الخدمات الطبية بواحد من أجل  تقول
الأم للطفل التي لديها
المهارات والمعدات اللازمة
والمبادئ التوجيهية المحدثة من قبل المنظمة أن
أفضل المرشحات للولادة في المنزل
يحملن أيضًا جنينًا واحدًا ليس
مقعديًا أو حاملًا على الأقل 37 أسبوعًا
وليس لديه تاريخ سابق للولادة القيصرية
وفقًا لتوصية مراكز
السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها ، يشير
التقرير إلى أنه يجب فحص جميع النساء الحوامل
من 35 إلى 37 أسبوعًا بالنسبة
للنساء المصابات بالبكتيريا العقدية من المجموعة ب اللائي
يخططن للولادة في المنزل ، يجب إعطاؤهن
مضادًا حيويًا في المنزل قبل أربع ساعات على الأقل من
الولادة  قبل الولادة في المنزل ،
تأكد من وجود طريقة للتواصل مع
المنشأة الطبية في حالة الطوارئ
والاستعداد للحصول على مكان آمن  يجب أن يكون النقل في الوقت المناسب
في حالة حدوث
مضاعفات متاحًا لطبيب أو
قابلة معتمدة ومرخصة
ويجب ألا يبعد أقرب مستشفى عن 20
دقيقة في حالة حدوث خطأ ما ، فإن الحالة
الأساسية أو الموجودة مسبقًا
هي أي مشكلة صحية مزمنة أو طويلة الأجل
يمكن أن يضعف جهاز المناعة
وعندما تقاتل فيروسًا ، نحتاج
إلى أن تكون أجهزتنا المناعية في أفضل حالاتها
وفقًا للمراكز الأمريكية لمكافحة
الأمراض والوقاية منها ، فهذه
بعض الحالات التي يمكن أن تؤثر على
استجابة الجسم لمحاربة كورونا
أمراض الرئة الفيروسية ، الربو أو أمراض القلب ،
كل هذه تؤثر
على قدرة الجسم على محاربة
الفيروس المعروف بمهاجمته للرئتين ، وهذا
بدوره يجبر القلب على العمل بجدية أكبر من
أولئك الذين يعانون من ضعف المناعة بسبب
العلاجات الطبية المستمرة مثل
متلقي الأعضاء أو ربما أولئك الذين  كان لديك فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية
أو الإيدز السمنة الشديدة أي شخص
لديه مؤشر كتلة الجسم 40 أو أعلى من
مرض السكري والكلى والكبد و
قد تعرضك حالات النمو العصبي أيضًا
لخطر أكبر للإصابة بعدوى خطيرة
بفيروس كورونا
وبالطبع العمر وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) ، فإن البالغين الذين
يبلغون من العمر 65 عامًا أو أكبر ليسوا فقط أكثر عرضة
للإصابة بحالات صحية طويلة الأمد ولكن
نظام المناعة لدينا يضعف مع تقدمنا في السن إن وج
ت.  من بين هذه الأمور تنطبق عليك الآن أكثر من
أي وقت مضى ، من المهم أن تبقى في المنزل وأن
تظل آمنًا خلال اللحظة الصحية لليوم ، أنا
ميليسا تمطر
عليك